[Musique]
bonheur le bonheur est partout le
bonheur aujourd'hui il est en famille
faut être heureux il faut être heureux
au restaurant il faut être heureux
le week end il faut être heureux toute
la journée
d'ailleurs il ya qu à voir sur les
réseaux sociaux
au premier rang duquel instagram cette
espèce d'outils maléfique qui nous
injecte des images de gens parfaitement
heureux toute la journée des gens qui
sont tous beaux ils sont aussi tous
mince c'est des gens qui mangent bio
c'est des gens qui font du yoga en
famille et c'est des gens qui ont tous
invariablement un job génial donc
aujourd'hui le bonheur est effectivement
partout il faut donc être heureux c'est
devenu une obligation c'est devenu
incontournable
même au travail effectivement au travail
être heureux c'est devenu une norme
c'est devenu la norme
et quiconque se refuse à adhérer à cette
norme se retrouve immédiatement taxées
d'ostracisme mis au rebut de la société
puisque aujourd'hui être heureux au
travail figurez vous que c'est facile
c'est simple aujourd'hui il existe plein
de trucs pour nous rendre heureux au
travail
aujourd'hui il existe de la littérature
sur le bonheur au travail
aujourd'hui il existe des documentaires
il existe aussi des webzines sur le
bonheur au travail des comptes twitter
sur le bonheur au travail
il existe des newsletters des
newsletters qui nous injecte des dose de
bonne humeur tous les mois dans nos
boîtes mail pour que jamais on fasse la
gueule le lundi matin au travail
il existe aussi des labels des labels
qui classe les entreprises dans
lesquelles il fait bon vivre des
entreprises dans lesquelles tous les
salariés sont il existe aussi des goûts
ou alors des gourous du bonheur au
travail en général ce sont des patrons
pour qu'ils travaillent et procure une
joie transcendantale cosmique
il existe aussi des applications des
applications qui permettent de mesurer
le bonheur des collaborateurs et j'ai
l'honneur de vous annoncer qu'il existe
aussi un mot en danois qui veut dire
bonheur au travail
personnellement j'arrive absolument pas
à le prononcer mais en tout cas sachez
que qu'il existe seulement voilà on n'a
jamais autant parlé de bonheur au
travail et on n'a jamais autant parlé
deux bornes
le burn out vous voyez c'est ce syndrome
de l'épuisement professionnel
c'est cette maladie qui a à peine dix
ans nous est hyper flipper compenser
complètement réservée aux salariés
japonais qui se faisait tyranniser 12
heures par jour par leur manager vie
c'est alors c'est à leur chaise au
bureau et bien aujourd'hui le burn out
et partout le burn out est chez nous et
aujourd'hui les chiffres sont
franchement alarmant
alors évidemment les chiffres varient en
fonction des sources c'est pas la même
chose selon que ce soit l'assurance
maladie qui parle ou les syndicats ou
des cabinets privés
en revanche ce qu'on peut dire c'est
qu'à peu près aujourd'hui on estime à un
tiers des salariés concernés par la
souffrance au travail
cher c'est énorme au delà du fait que
les chiffres soient exponentielle
aujourd'hui les pathologies se
diversifie après le
peur j'ai le plaisir de vous annoncer le
bord le bord out c'est la maladie de
l'ennui au travail mais mais figurez
vous c'est l'ennui des gens qui tombent
malades tellement ils s'emmerdent dans
leurs bureaux
il existe aussi une troisième catégorie
de pathologie professionnelle jeu
probablement ma préférée en tout cas la
plus croustillante qui touche d'ailleurs
un nombre assez considérable de cadres
il s'agit du black out
lebron à otc la maladie de l'absurdité
au travail
lebron a haussé la maladie des gens qui
croule sous des tâches tellement
incompréhensible absurde sous des
directives incohérente qu'ils en tombe
malade c'est la maladie des gens qui ne
savent même plus pourquoi ils vont
bosser le matin c'est la maladie une des
gens qui n'ont plus aucun sens dans leur
travail est d'ailleurs sincèrement il
suffit d'un apéro entre copines d'un
dîner de famille d'un barbecue avec des
potes pour se rendre est très vite
compte que ce que je vous dis c'est pas
n'importe quoi ainsi ce soir par exemple
qui parmi vous est parfaitement heureux
au travail
normalement vous devriez être un tiers
qui parmi vous a trouvé la solution
miraculeuse de l' équilibre parfait
entre votre vie pro et votre vie perso
pas mal on en parlera après vous nous
direz vos recettes qui n'a jamais songé
à voir un coach pour repositionner votre
carrière qui n'a jamais songé à vous à
se reconvertir pour devenir je sais pas
sophrologue ouvrir bar alternatif
bref pour devenir faire de la médecine
chinoise ou ouvrir une chambre d'hôtes
en tout cas à en croire les chiffres et
les statistiques on serait franchement
assez nombreux a pas l'avoir trouvé ce
fameux bonheur au travail qui nous
attend à la porte de nos open space
et alors ça je peux vous dire qu'il y en
a qui l'ont très très très bien compris
c'est les petits génies du marketing du
management et j'ai la joie ce soir de
vous annoncer qu'il existe par exemple
un kit anti burn-out donc pour 60 balles
vous pouvez vous procurer ce petit kit
ce qui vous permet avec un spread
oreillers des cachets et des gouttes de
donc vous guérir de votre burn out
mais c'est pas tout si par exemple dans
votre open space
vous avez un collègue j'ai pas mangé
rare qui tape beaucoup trop fort avec
ses gros doigts sur son clavier à côté
de vous et que ça vous agace
et bien sachez que pour 299 euros
vous pouvez vous procurer cette
merveille ceci étant une houillère
d'open space
donc c'était hier d'open space vous
permettra non seulement de ne plus
entendre gérardmer en plus de plus le
voir donc vous pourrez pas séjourné au
travail parfaitement sereine et il
existe aussi des gens dont c'est le
métier de vous rendre heureux au travail
ce sont les chief business officer les
feelgood manager
les community builder les apidays
designer whey alors j'ai le droit d'en
parler parce que moi aussi j'ai exercé
cette cette belle profession
personne n'est parfait cette belle
profession qui d'ailleurs que m'a
beaucoup apporté que j'ai que j'ai
vraiment beaucoup aimé exercer mais en
revanche j'ai très vite compris les
limites quand même donc si je comprends
bien en tout cas aujourd'hui il
semblerait que face à sète à ce syndrome
du de la souffrance au travail mais
personne ne s'est dit qu'il fallait
peut-être commencer à réfléchir à notre
rapport au travail qu'il fallait
peut-être commencer à peut-être se dire
de qu'il fallait travailler un peu moins
peut-être bannir les managers tyrannique
peut-être en finir avec les process
inutile bien non non non
la solution était bien plus simple
évidente tout de suite facilement
accessibles il s'agit de nous amener du
bonheur au travail et donc c'est ainsi
qu'on s'est retrouvée envahie par des
baby foots par des tables de ping pong
par des corbeilles de fruits à faire des
cours de yoga collectif à manger des
fraises tagada tous ensemble en équipe
et c'est ainsi que moi je me suis
retrouvée
à jouer aux lego ou à prendre un cours
de cuisine avec avec mes boss et je sais
pas vous mais moi en tout cas ça
m'angoisse
alors ça m'angoisse pas en soi mais
c'est que sincèrement si je dois échangé
avec mon boss c'est pas pour apprendre à
faire une mayonnaise
c'est plutôt pour qu'ils me donnent un
cadre de travail clair efficace des
moyens pour travailler bien au quotidien
un cadre compréhensible clair bref tout
ça pour dire que aujourd'hui on nage
dans un océan d'injonction
contradictoires qui non seulement nous
rendent complètement dingue mais en plus
nous épuise
alors je vais vous donner un exemple
parmi d'autres mais un matin je sors de
la station métro miromesnil et je tombe
sur cette affiche le 18 octobre mesdames
et messieurs ont fait sa boîte le 18
octobre
tout le monde est content au travail
puisque c'est la journée j'aime ma boîte
la journée du bonheur au travail
en parallèle je vais acheter mon petit
magazine néo à mon kiosque à journaux et
néons petits traits cette semaine là
enquête sur la dictature du bonheur
culte du sourire gourou du bien-être
soit heureux et tais toi donc désormais
il fonde non seulement être le plus
performant il faut de toute façon avoir
fait la bonne école ça c'est la base
globalement ensuite c'est quand même
mieux d'être beau et jeune parce que
c'est mieux sur la photo
mais en plus il faut jamais faire la
gueule ça c'est mal aujourd'hui ce qui
fait que on se retrouve comme un hamster
qui court dans sa roue après un espèce
d'hypothétiques bonheur qu'on trouve
jamais alors même qu'il est là elle est
le baby foot il est là et moi je cours
après un bonheur dans un espèce de
surinvestissement complètement funeste
malheureusement je suis navré d'avoir à
vous dire ce soir que le bonheur c'est
quelque chose de privé
c'est quelque chose de subjectif c'est
quelque chose qui est intime
mon critère de bonheur n'est absolument
pas le même que le tiens on que le vôtre
ou que le vôtre et du coup il est
absolument impossible de manipuler le
bonheur en vue d'une quelconque
performance en entreprise
c'est non seulement impossible mais en
plus c'est malhonnête et ça ça nous
conduit à un surinvestissement
complètement néfastes bien loin de nous
apaiser
ça nous abymes alors on fait quoi alors
je serai très présent tueuse de vous
amener des solutions toutes faites et
des recettes miracles d'abord si j'en
avais je serai millionnaire donc voilà
jean journée pas socrate disait ce que
je sais c'est que je ne sais rien moi
non plus je ne sais rien en revanche ce
soir je vais partager avec vous des
intuitions des convictions et peut-être
humblement me permettent de ramener un
tout petit peu de bon sens dans cette
espèce de grosse boule sheetrit général
alors on fait quoi eh bien d'abord il
est urgent de ne rien faire
d'abord on s'assoit deux minutes voilà
on réfléchit on prend un pas de côté et
on essaye de prendre de la hauteur par
rapport à tout ça parce que je sais pas
vous mais moi en fait cette espèce de
tyrannie continue sur le bonheur
notamment au travail
ça me donne la sensation d'être une
mamie de 190 ans qu'est scotché sur mon
banc et qui regarde les gens s'agiter
autour de moi sans comprendre ce qu'est
en train de se passer
non seulement je comprends pas comment
on a pu en arriver là mais en plus je me
sens hyper coupable ne pas participer à
la joie générale quoi sauf que si on
fait un tout petit pas de côté bien on
se rend compte que la notion de bonheur
et de travail ont été deux concepts au
cours de lustre de l'histoire
parfaitement antithétiques parfaitement
opposé pendant l'antiquité par exemple
pour les grecs
la valeur qui était promue comme valeur
ultime au sein de la société c'était
absolument pas le travailleur c'est l
oisiveté
c'était le calme c'était la
contemplation c'était la recherche de la
vérité la recherche de la vie bonne
l'argonne en grec elle même étant
parfaitement opposés aux ponots
le ponot c'est l'activité c'est le dur
labeur c'est l'action ge et les romains
c'est pareil chez les romains le nèg au
siom c'est la négativité de l'otium
l'otium celle oisiveté le calme donc en
fait pendant des millénaires ils étaient
de mauvais tours de travailler s'ajoute
à cela à cette vision très négative du
monde du travail durant à peu près à
l'époque chrétienne et de l'europe et
durant tout le moyen-âge d'ailleurs une
vision encore plus négative néfastes
maléfique du travail
si on prend la génèse dieu chasse adam
du jardin d'éden
après qu'ils aient mangé sa pomme
ils le chassent en le bannissant et en
lui disant tu travailleras à la sueur de
ton front
le ciel sera maudit par ta faute et tu
auras grand peine en tirait la
nourriture donc le travail devient
sacrificielle pénible difficile dure et
c'est d'ailleurs ce cette notion qu'on
retrouve dans l'étymologie du mot
travail travail ça vient en latin du mot
trepalium qui veut dire torturé avec le
trepalium le trepalium c'est un outil de
torture à trois pions c'est à peu près
entre le 16e et le 18e siècle que les
choses commencent à changer avec la
réforme protestante l'éthique
capitaliste la travailler dur faire
fortune réussir devient signe plus tôt
d'élections divine on gagne durement sa
vie ici bas pour gagner sa place au
paradis
si bien qu'aujourd'hui on se retrouve
dans une société où l'élite est une
élite laborieuse l'élite qui travaillent
qui travaillent dur quand on dit de
quelqu'un qui travaille beaucoup
sa force notre espèce en revanche
quelqu'un qui travaille pas beaucoup un
oisif il est vu comme un paresseux
ça c'est le mieux sinon comme un
parasite je vous raconte ça c'est pas du
tout pour vous dire qu'on peut pas être
heureux au travail
moi même je place le plaisir au centre
de mes préoccupations professionnelles
d'ailleurs c'est mon point de vue vous
vous pouvez placer la créativité
l'autonomie que sage est prêt je vous
dis ça pour vous faire comprendre que
cette notion se raccourcit de travail
égal bonheur c'est un mythe contemporain
très récent c'est une distorsion moderne
et que bien loin de nous apaiser
non seulement ça nous mène à une espèce
de quête infernal mais en plus ça
brouille notre capacité à nous poser les
bonnes questions
les bonnes questions c'est pas du tout
de savoir comment faire pour être
heureux avec un baby foot au travail les
bonnes questions c'est comment faire
pour que nos entreprises se transforme
en profondeur pour qu'on puisse avoir
plus de sens dans nos activités au
quotidien et donc potentiellement il
prend plus de plaisir
la vraie question c'est comment on
switch d'une entreprise pyramidale
hier archi zay basé sur l'ego sur le
pouvoir sur le commandement le contrôle
des entreprises avec des fiches de poste
en silos des entreprises qui favorisent
la compétition des entreprises qui sont
globalement quand même profondément
injuste vers des entreprises plus plate
plus organique des entreprises qui
favorisent la solidarité le lien la
coopération la collaboration on est plus
intelligent à dix cerveaux qu'à un
cerveau des entreprises donc qui
promeuvent l'intelligence collective
bref des entreprises qui permettent plus
de liberté de responsabilité donc fuck
le bonheur et vive la liberté c'est en
étant plus libre et plus responsable
qu'on pourra peut-être produire un
meilleur travail donner du sens à nos
actions et donc peut-être en tirer plus
de satisfaction alors quand je dis
liberté ça veut pas dire freestyle
généralisée bordel général on fait tout
ce qu'on veut il n'y a pas de règle
bien entendu que le monde du travail
nécessite des liens de subordination le
monde du travail nécessite des cadres
des règles et c'est bien normal mais
dans ce cadre on a plein d espace à se
réapproprier des espaces de liberté
qu'il faut conquérir autrement dit le
hamster dans sa cage il n'est pas obligé
de tourner dix heures par jour dans sa
roue en fait il peut tout à fait sortir
de sa roue est allé se balader il a même
le droit de temps en temps de sortir de
sa cage donc c'est exactement là qu'il
faut agir c'est sur ces espaces de
liberté pour ma part j'ai jamais
considéré que j'étais limité une fiche
de poste au cours de ma carrière je me
suis toujours attribué la possibilité
d'aller choper des nouveau challenge
quand il se présentait à moi est
absolument pas me limiter aux objectifs
qui m'étaient un parti en début d'année
par ailleurs il me semble qu'aujourd'hui
on peut se permettre et c'est plutôt une
bonne nouvelle de commencer à interroger
notre rapport au travail
la linéarité de nos carrières le
cinq jours par semaine full time
aujourd'hui on peut l'interroger on peut
se permettre
je sais pas moi une demi journée par
mois pour nous pour travailler sur autre
chose avec d'autres gens pour sinon
faire la même chose mais pour d'autres
entreprises ou pour acquérir de
nouvelles connaissances ce 1/2 jours par
mois peut devenir une demi journée par
semaine
pour ma part je suis passionné
d'histoire de l'art et ben j'ai aucun
problème à aller à l'école du louvre et
à faire d'autres choses en plus de ce
que je peux faire au quotidien
en revanche pour ça ça nécessite d'être
courageux ça nécessite d'être courageux
pour se lever de son banc pour devenir
agissant et pour faire bouger les lignes
ça nécessite d'être courageux pour
refuser d'être les collabos consentants
d'un système à bout de souffle
thucydide disait au cinquième siècle le
secret du bonheur c'est la liberté et le
secret de la liberté c'est le courage
ayons donc le courage de nous
réapproprier nos espaces de liberté car
ces deux sens d'autodétermination de
responsabilité de justice nous avons
besoin dans nos entreprises mais
certainement pas que nos employeurs se
charge de notre bonheur non seulement
parce qu'on il ya bien d'autres choses à
gérer il me semble avant et on l'a vu en
termes de priorités
mais par ailleurs parce que le bonheur
on est bien assez grand pour s'en
occuper tout seul au travail mais pas
que donc le bonheur au travail
merci mais non merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]